I don't think that you should be quoted
in print before you turn 28 mmm I was
largely driven by wanting people to like
me and approve of me so I would say
things that I didn't really believe and
oftentimes that backfired
what about to go with me Josh Smith and
today we're joined by the queen of our
teens and now you're starring in the
second season of Riviera's genius style
what I love about Riviera is it is very
juicy
oh it's ripping in drama and juice it's
dripping in gold LeMay which is the way
I want to live my life well I think it's
really amazing about your careers you
have a very unique perspective on how
the industry's changed so obviously you
pass on to our scenes in like the late
90s early noughties so glass starts 10
Things I Hate About You 7 or films which
people are still talking about which
shows how incredible that kind of work
is and now you're having this amazing
show with Riviere how do you think in
the space your career the position of
women has changed and the representation
of women would you say I think 10 years
ago I would have been afraid of becoming
an actress in her late 30s and now
almost because of these conversations I
can breathe a sigh of relief and I feel
like the opportunities for me and my
peers are better and better as we get
older you just said that when you like
10 years ago you would being quite
scared of being an actress in your late
30s what impression did you have of the
industry at that point in your life to
have that idea in your head most of my
roles were the roles that came my way
and with my peers as well you were
either the girlfriend or eventually
you'd shift over into the mom and the
two were not interchangeable but the
role that I wanted so desperately was
cat in 10 Things I Hate About You and it
was because I'd never seen such a feisty
mm-hmm teenage girl on screen before I
mean I know that there are examples of
them but for me it was like an
opportunity to play this woman was new
and exciting but it was few and far
between and I didn't think that that
could continue can you remember a time
in your career where you felt like you
couldn't speak up about something or you
were on the setting like no I want to do
it this way I want to do it that way or
you like you want to make your opinion
of it you didn't feel like you're in a
space we could let that happen I mean
I've worked with bullies without naming
names I
was screened out on a set and burst into
tears my first day of work and the
producers essentially came to me and
said this is this is how it goes so that
message to me was you have to take this
kind of behavior if everybody else
around you is accepting it then you have
to as well now that would never fly
there's so many discussions around toxic
masculinity now yeah and there's been
toxic masculinity what you saying about
someone screaming you at the face and
how have you when you come across that
how have you dealt with toxic
masculinity and what would you say to
someone out there who might be dealing
with it what advice would you want to
give to them it really depends on the
situation and the context you know I
would love to say that in that situation
I should have shouted back at him or I
should have said you can't talk to me
like that but it wasn't the right
situation to do that in and I feel like
ultimately I won because I was still in
the movie hmm
but you just you have to have standards
and you have to judge where someone will
cross the line and what you're willing
to put up with the only way we can
further the conversations if we bring
men onto the course like either male
feminists and people should be joining
that cause as well don't you think
that's what we need today I'm also
raising a white boy mmm so what does
that mean you know and I my husband said
the most beautiful thing when we were at
the playground and some other parent
looked at my son and he was playing with
I think a fire engine and she said what
are you gonna be when you grow up are
you gonna be a fireman and my husband
chimed in and he said I just want you to
be kind wonderful that's so cute I think
also one of the most amazing things
that's come out of the meaty movement is
discussion around pay gaps mm-hmm which
is finally thank God because women
should be paid as like the same as men
there's no point in your career where
you've been aware of that when I get on
the phone with my lawyer about just
recently about what I was going to be
paid on a little movie that I did they
pointed out to me that I was going to be
making less than the lead actor and it
was my choice to accept that or not go
into more detail because it's boring and
champagne problems but but it's a
conversation it's now taking really
seriously what is your career
taught you about success and failure and
how have you coped with failure and how
has that made success more important to
you I look back on a lot of my career
and I really want to do overall not many
things where I now look how can I go I
you know I would love to have that
experience again or I would have handled
this differently or even just in terms
of my performance would have done I
would have known what to do better but I
learned from it oh so I can't really
look at it as a failure what would you
want to do over if you could like every
role until I was probably yesterday and
um no I don't think that you should be
quoted in print before you turn 25 28
mm-hm
you pick a number it depends on the
person yeah I shouldn't have been quoted
in print why well because it's like just
figuring out what all of this is the
entertainment industry I was largely
driven by wanting people to like me and
approve of me because you're so used to
as an act you're auditioning and wanting
people to hire you and that means liking
you so I would say things that I didn't
really believe or think to be true it
was just to what people were encouraging
me to say what I thought would get a
laugh on a talk show and oftentimes that
backfired in fact the the farther away I
was from my own truth the more that
would backfire can you name a time in
particular that's happened I can I mean
there's been many times I went on a
late-night talk show I think it was
Conan O'Brien or David Letterman I was
in college at the time I was talking
about college life and and you know they
asked me if I ate in the cafeteria like
a normal kid I rambled on because I was
insecure and I think I used the term
mole people but my thought in it was
there was an Adam Sandler song at the
time where it was there was a character
on a sketch comedy show where he was
playing the lunch lady and she had a
hairnet and a mole then a backfired and
on a very like immediate level the
people that I was in school with were
furious with me and they call it they've
somebody wrote in the school newspaper
she's an elitist you know she how dare
she insult the cafeteria workers which
was so not my intention and not Who I am
as a person and to know that the the
people that were working hard in
school cleaning up the garbage feeding
us meals thought that I was insulting
them was so devastating to me because it
was absolutely not my intention so
anyway I went and I wrote something in
the paper I issued I wrote a handwritten
apology to the to the cafeteria workers
but I learned a valuable lesson aside
from you know think before you speak it
that kind of thing is so exaggerated now
because of social media you do have to
be careful about how what you say is
perceived in the impact that it will
have how is your relationship with your
own body image changed as you've seen it
change on screen and are you much more
one with yourself now or can you
remember times when you were Leslie so
somebody asked me if you could tell your
younger self something about give give
your younger self advice on acne my
answer was actually stop hating on your
body I used to put on clothes for a red
carpet and be so uncomfortable just
because I was trying to look good that
it took away from the whole experience
and enjoying the experience and now I'm
very conscious of making sure that I
feel confident in how I step out into
the world obviously you were in a very
empowering show and it's fabulous
Riviera what is the one message to
finish off one message empowerment you'd
want to give the audience out there an
important life lesson for me is that you
cannot control other people's behavior
whether they bully you whether they put
you down whether they lift you up all
you can do is control your your how you
internalize it your response to it how
you react to it amazing thank you so
much thank you for more empowering
interviews like this with such
empowering people like Julia make sure
you subscribe to the glamour and UK
channels now
you